rodman absolutely on fire
first stretch there in the second half
looking to light it up again
washington
takes the lead
[Applause]
that was the game-winning goal for the
washington spirit at last year's
national women's soccer league
championship only on cbs mornings we are
very excited to announce the new
commissioner of the league it is veteran
professional sports executive jessica
berman she spent two and a half years as
the deputy commissioner for the national
lacrosse league and before that was a
vice president at the nhl for 13 years
and jessica joins us now for her very
first interview as commissioner
madame commissioner good morning good
morning congratulations
thank you
thank you this is something you and i
could probably talk about for hours
being the only woman in a sports
dominated sphere it is different
but what does it mean now to be the head
of a female sports league in
i guess the idea that people always
think sports men sports men
well i'm very aware of the fact that i
don't look like the other people who
work in the sports industry and if i
ever forget that i have my two boys who
were 14 and 11 to remind me and actually
when i was offered the opportunity to be
the deputy commissioner of the national
cross league and i was the first female
deputy commissioner of a men's sports
league i went to my family my children
and i said
can we do this because i knew it was
going to be a huge sacrifice and it was
actually my older son who said to me
you're a pioneer you have to do this mom
it's how you change perception by making
this the norm
the nwsl has had a problem in recent
months with with culture
coaches being fired allegations of
abusive behavior
it's a cultural problem potentially that
you need to fix how do you approach that
well first of all the health and safety
of our players is the utmost priority
both emotionally and physically we're
i'm fortunate that i'm walking into a
situation where over the last six months
things have really stabilized under the
current leadership and with the board
and we're now working in conjunction
with the players association and all the
players to
handle the investigation and make sure
that we put forward the type of league
that every player feels proud to play in
it does seem like this league has
created this new wave of fans and these
women are household names i mean right
up there with some of the most popular
athletes in the world you know megan
rapino alex morgan carly lloyd um how do
you use the popularity of them in the
players
to create a
more exciting league
let's be honest these women are icons
not just email icons they are icons and
these athletes are worth watching and i
am so excited to celebrate them and make
sure that everyone at home knows that
they can watch us on cbs laughs
starting soon
wait every four years we are here we are
here and we share players with the
women's national team so you can watch
those same players in our league and i'm
so excited to support them and celebrate
their stories madam commissioner let me
ask you about this recent pay settlement
and what that means for the future of
women's soccer well as i just mentioned
we share players with the women's
national team and so we couldn't be
happier that they were able to resolve
their dispute with u.s soccer federation
and it really paves the way for us to
move forward because of course equal pay
for equal work is something i think we
all can subscribe to
in our league we actually also just
reached an agreement with our players
association with a new collective
bargaining agreement which really sets
the standards for all of our teams to
follow my background is that i'm a labor
lawyer so i'm a firm believer in the
partnership that exists with our union i
like to say it's a marriage where you
can't get a divorce we have to work
together and that will be my priority
moving forward we don't have a lot of
time and it's probably not a fair
question to ask in that but i'll try
this idea not just equal pay
within a sport but across the board with
women in men's sports they do have
different audiences they do have
different tv deals and all of that do
you think we're starting to edge closer
where we do see those higher pay scales
in some of the women's sports it's
happening you're seeing it in soccer you
see it in tennis right i'm a huge fan of
the us open
and the female athletes that play in
those sports are really starting to
transcend the cultural narrative that's
right and we we have to also be aware
that we are a business right and so it
has to be built sustainably but i think
certainly for these
athletes in the nwsl they have proven
their worth and they deserve to be
celebrated and acknowledged
madam commissioner congratulations
congratulations
welcome thank you and we mentioned it
cbs sports is the home of the nwsl the
2022 nwsl challenge cup kicks off friday
march 18th oh my gosh that's around the
corner it's across cbs platforms
including cbs cbs sports network and
paramount plus